hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and I'm Gretchen and this is Tamra's
never seen and today we are watching the
1995 classic Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers only on a show like this am I
the appropriate person to be reviewing
this movie because I've never seen you
we actually did find a couple of things
but they were like the two of the only
movies that are not streaming anywhere
right now
yeah and jokingly you said like I don't
know it could be something dumb like the
Power Rangers movie ago I actually grew
up watching the show my brother and I
would dress up as the Power Rangers we
loved the show but I never saw the movie
this came out when I was four so I just
I didn't see the theater well I was 14
when this movie came out so I at 14 I
felt like I was a little too old for
this so at 37 I our Rangers was a couple
years past like my time really like I
was in the class at school where it like
wasn't cool to watch Power Rangers if I
was a little bit younger it might have
been something I was maybe into but yeah
it was it just really it just went by me
having loved it growing up I do feel
like I'm a little nervous to go into it
I feel like I'm not going to enjoy it
that much oh no this is gonna be
timeless this is gonna be one of those
movies where you'd be like it works for
every decade I can't tell when this was
made we'd better like this because I
think Amy Joe Johnson is at the
convention we're going to this weekend
it's gonna be really awkward if this
turns up we're gonna have to go up and
confront I mean we're not mad we're
disappointed mm-hmm okay one two three
[Music]
you
I was wrong about this big tightness you
know what this movie is do you remember
the episode of The Simpsons when they go
to the kwik-e-mart and they part has $20
and he gets the slushy that's only made
just entirely of Sarah okay
he just gets one made of just like pure
sugar and they go on a big sugar binge
and he wakes up and he's joined the
junior campers by mistake
much like after watching this
[Laughter]
simultaneously I loved some of the
cheesiness of Italy sure it's like they
had a guidebook of terrible 90s
catchphrases and every other line they
were like Oh figures a good 100 awesome
man I've got a bone to pick with you
Oh Oh even if they're just by themselves
like if they're just saying a one-liner
like just all alone like you deeds
wouldn't do would okay I said that you
know what like reading a book in their
bathtub later Gator
yeah it's it's one of those movies were
for your heroes all of their lines can
be followed up by the nut the other
person just going you can say that again
and with the villains the all of their
lines could easily be Hiro says
something and villain would go it's the
Soulja or I just have a sweet spot where
but I loved that I also loved the music
and all of the sound cues oh boy okay if
there was anything surprising about this
movie it was a couple of choices on the
soundtrack how some of it makes sense
like you expect to be in a movie like
this yeah the ending credits where it's
played like a club remix of kungfu
fighting right of course there was a
couple times like I was not expecting
there to be like this skate sequence
with
playing the Edgar Winter coups free
right during this like it's if I close
my eyes I'm listening to the soundtrack
of a Rob Zombie fellow all they did
workstreams
oh yeah diving out of an airplane and
then intentionally rollerblading
everywhere at the end it's laying dreams
by Van Halen yep you got me movie this
truly is what dreams are made remember
my favorite thing about this movie
coming out stick critics review bit
deeper and we give Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers two jobs yeah I couldn't tell if
that was because of the blue beer
because of the quality of the copy of
the eye so I don't enjoy streaming
movies illegally I think that's so lame
of me to say out loud but like I really
just I'll pay the $3 to rent the floor
movie and we couldn't find this anywhere
so it was on YouTube and the only way
booth watches on YouTube for free with
Indonesian subject so it was very grainy
and I think it helped some feel like CGI
you were saying it kind of did a little
bit I'm like right it's to this movies
benefit we are not watching this on blue
I was trying to think like am I really
that above this movie really cuz I was
thinking about the things I did like
back then so in my head I'm comparing it
to like the first two Ninja Turtles
movies yeah but I was also thinking it's
like did I enjoy those because I was the
right age at the time certainly but
there are things about those movies that
are legitimately way better than this
film at the very least those movies do
look the actor yes yeah there's such a
difference between this didn't be dog
Rafi in most films of it so also you get
I know that you get a lot of like
character development from the Power
Rangers in
and then they expect you have seen that
and now you're watching the movie so you
know them but like in those movies you
got so much character work on April Emil
oh yeah Casey Jones did you got to know
them really well
it sets up that world too it's a really
gritty kind of universe yeah yeah yeah
and it just like if the puppetry looks
really cool and like I will give it that
the costumes and the makeup in this are
pretty interesting and engaging and like
the names you know Ivan ooze the most
insufferable part is the robot saying
III am stop trying to make fetch happen
it's never gonna happen like I don't
know many fans of this show will get
this callback yeah visually speaking
speaking like that there are different
kinds of effects that are in this movie
versus the show but it is still acted
like a Saturday morning television
series yeah like through and through the
acting does not change really from the
show over to this even a lot of the
lighting is as well as I saw the 2017
wait and I kind of liked it just fine in
that movie I understand why that movie
took about 80% of it to set up the
characters a movie like quite a bit of
that movie is about character building
yeah and I like that about the movie
then I really like it now because it
almost seemed to be doing that to make
up for this remember bits and pieces
from watching the show yeah like
different things for the different
characters and like we you they were
built up for sure and that like it was
such a phenomena on the show so then
well you've seen the show when you see
the movie
so they didn't put anything you know
which is a little weird like you get
nothing on these characters yeah
like they're introduced by a catchphrase
like bazinga
sir ha ha ha if ever there was an
example of what they say about a lot of
90s like comic book movies that a lot of
them were geared more towards building
up the villains and the heroes this
movie is like the prime example of the
villains are set up in this movie might
as well they spent so much money on the
bank up we're showing that stuff there
are those kind of villains like we're
talking about this we were watching it
where it's like kind of like hocus pocus
rules where they existed like a thousand
years ago but they get all of our slang
and they're like super in to the point
where key references The Brady Bunch
oh yeah I forgot about that yeah you
ready he takes a shot at the Brady Bunch
Oh what movie are you really sure you
want to be throwing shade at the Brady
Bunch
so funny and random if this I think this
movies like a PT if because it's
theatrical how like jarring it would
have been if they allowed like one
person word like well the sit in
the bed like the power rangers show up
in Ivan ooze is like oh this is
embarrassing to say because I shouldn't
have but I had a hard time following the
plot of this movie it just I was so
focused on the stupid catchphrases it
just the cheesiness was just hard to
wade through but really I don't know why
were they fighting dinosaur fossils yes
where did that come from
dinosaurs they're at the legends of the
Hidden Temple at the end there's
watching this movie I was like people
need to start going easy
like Italy you know as dumb as Batman
and Robin is cuz really both movies kind
of feel like they're in the same
universe like Batman and Robin
Italy like say what you will about how
dumb it is it's a three Episode sequence
of Power Rangers yeah turned into a
movie and yeah it chooses one fight
scene to another to another to another
to another and that's really just the
movie yeah that is it it kind of made it
feel really well we first like closet
for a moment yeah 30 minutes it gone by
and it's like how is that science how is
that possible oh that's okay I think one
of the Rotten Tomatoes reviews was also
how is this science a lot of this
brought me back to watching the show and
if I would have seen this in 95 I think
I would have loved it yeah and I'm
watching it now it certainly hasn't aged
well although I did enjoy some aspects
of it that newer movie that came out
yeah it's a better a better pace
but they are both different movies for
different scenarios yes if you're
getting together and you have a group of
friends together and you're drinking or
something you probably don't want to put
on the you want to watch this yeah
exactly I wish I was asked like a
critics greeting for this back in 95
what was that conversation like after 1
million percent thank you so much for
joining me of course they came through
this Indonesian YouTube rip up our rage
it worked out in so many ways because
neither of us had seen if you're also
looking for something like 90 minutes
yeah so that's really what we got out of
it isn't really that was 90 minute oh
yeah thank you so much for watching I'll
see you all next week bye great do you
think you're gonna watch the second one
No
[Music]
[Applause]
you